dans le beau département du
rô je vous invite à vous rendre à
Charlie mais également à
Pontoise nous attendons Monsieur
Emmanuel François qui est le maire de
Saint-Pierre
descor et nous aur en vis Monsieur Serge
decli qui est le maire de montsmartin
Meur
etit alors est-ce qu'il est branché oui
ah voilà
vous nous entendez Monsieur le Maire
vous entends très bien bonjour parfait
nous vous entendons également et en plus
nous vous voyons c'est
parfait très
bien je vous propose que nous débuons
notre réunion je rappelle à chacun et
chacune d'entre
vous membres de la commission des lois
que nous avons lancé cette
mission avec l'idée de connaître le plus
parfaitement possible ce qui s'est passé
au mois de juin dernier
s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît pouvez sortir éventuellement si
vous voulez c'est peut-être plus simple
je
crois o nous avons décidé de faire un
état des lieux assez
précis de la situation pour mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé bien sûr
que beaucoup de choses sont dites
beaucoup d'affirmations sont faites et
l'idée pour nous est d'aller au bout des
choses pour connaître parfaitement la
réalité de ces émeutes et singulièrement
en entendant nos je dis nos colollèg
maire parce que ici nous l'avons
quasiment tous été à peu près les élus
locaux qui ont eux-mêmes été victimes de
ces agressions directement ou
indirectement mais qui ont été j'is
mêlé à à ce climat de de violence
extrêmement fort mais au-delà du climat
lui-même en capacité de pouvoir nous
dire et nous expliquer ce qu'ils ont
compris de la situation sur leur
territoire et de l'interprétation qu'ils
ont de ce qu'ils ont vécu voilà donc je
vais leur donner la
parole il me semble que la parole va
tout naturellement à Madame Stéphanie V
qui est la maèire de Pontoise et puis
ensuite monsieur Olivia rogot puis
monsieur De Carli on attend l'arrivée
d'Emmanuel François le maire de
Saint-Pierre descor qui je pense ne va
pas tarder madame le Maire Madame la
Maire je sais pas ce que vous
préférez je suis assez conservatrice de
ce point de vue-là mais donc voilà donc
Madame le Maire mes ouvertes d'esprit
donc vous avez la parole merci merci
Monsieur le monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
d'abord merci de votre invitation euh
parce que à un moment et avec les
conséquences sans rentrer sur un autre
sujet mais la fin du cun des mandats il
est important effectivement que les
maires et quelle quelle enceinte
meilleure que le Sénat pour
effectivement faire remonter ce que nous
connaissons au quotidien vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président la plupart
d'entre vous avvez avveit été maire et
élu locaux le l'êre peut-être même
d'ailleurs encore la petite l'évolution
que moi je souhaite souligner c'est que
depuis 3 ans globalement et je pense que
mes collègues mes collègues Mar le
diront de la même façon que ce soit la
violence chronique du pays que ce soit
le postcovid que ce soit l'inflation et
autres je pense que nous avons une
situation en local qui n'a plus rien à
voir à ce qu'il qui avait il y a encore
TR ou TR ou 4 ans alors s'agissant des
des émeutes de fin juin et de et de tout
début juillet d'abord un constat puis
les quelques enseignements très
modestement que j'en tire à titre à
titre personnel Pontoise est une ville
de bientôt 40000 habitants en région
parisienne donc dans le dans le valdoise
qui a été touché j'allais dire comme
tout le monde ni plus ni moins peut-être
moins d'ailleurs que que d'autres
puisque nous avons eu la chance de ne
pas avoir de B bâtiments communaux
municipaux touchés touchés directement
mais pour autant la violence a été à
déferler hein pendant pendant trois
nuits je sais pas si vous imaginez mais
quand vous êtes maire et que vous
quittez chaque soir votre bureau en en
regardant en lançant un regard
circulaire en vous demandant si vous
allez retrouver votre bureau le
lendemain matin c'est quand même ça la
réalité de la situation pendant ces
trois nuits TR soirs et et tro nuit et
je me souviens c'est pour
l'anecdote mais un soir en repartant il
y avait mon écharpe tricolore qui qui
était accroché je l'ai attrapé en me
disant celle-là ils l'auront pas c'est
ça peut paraître anecdotique mais c'est
la réalité de ce que je pense que que
mes collègues ont vécu exactement la
même chose ce côté s'accrocher et
défendre coûte que coûte ce qui à nos
yeux n'a pas de prix à savoir les
valeurs républicaines et et et la
République en tant que telle donc des
violences des violences réel avec des
conséquences des dégâts matériels
évidemment je vais pas le détailler on n
probablement pas là pour pour ça euh des
agressions physiques il se trouve que
j'en ai été moi-même moi-même victime
personnellement visé parce que maire
parce que identifié en en faisant le
tour des quartiers qui vous étiez dans
votre voiture alors oui si vous voulez
je va pas raconter tout le détail mais
il faut raconter un peu parce que c'est
important de de voir ce que concrètement
vous avez vécu on a besoin de l'entendre
de le comprendre et compris de le
consigner alors euh à nous avons deux
quartiers politiques de la ville 10
quartiers prioritaires il se trouve que
j'étais sur l'un d'entre eux avec un
début d'incendie du théâtre que nous
avons circonscrit avec l'aide des
pompiers évidemment qui ont été formida
les les forces de l'ordre qui ont été
exceptionnel ma police municipal que je
tiens à saluer tout particulièrement qui
était primo intervenante et j et j'y
reviendrai et nous étions en train de
sécuriser le le site de manière à ce que
ça ne puisse pas se reproduire euh dès
que nous aurions tourné les talons à ce
moment-là nous avons été appelé sur un
début de d'un autre incendie d'une
concession automobile qui a d'ailleurs
malheureusement pour le coup elle
intégralement brûlé euh et à ce
moment-là vous ne réfléchissez pas je
suis montée dans ma voiture seul euh et
on ailé suivi par alors les forces de
l'ordre étaient passé de l'autre côté
moi j'avais la voiture du directeur de
cabinet du préfet qui me suivait et nous
avons été plus ou moins pris dans un
guetapanin avec donc des barricades
enflammées hein surtout sur toutes les
les les routes deuxème erreur la
première étant que je sois seulle dans
ma voiture et au volant deuxème erreur
c'est que je suis sortie de la voiture
pour aller constater pire encore c'est
dire à quel point je ne mesurais pas
finalement le le l'état de de de
j'allais dire je sais pas si c'est de
folie mais de délire ou d'excitation
générale et de violence complètement
désinhibée puisque je suis sortie de ma
voiture j'ai vu des jeunes approcher que
entre guillemets je connaissais sans p
pouvoir les reconnaître puisqu'ils
étaient intégralement masqués enfin avec
des des des foulards qui remontaient
jusqu'au nez des capuches qui
redescendaient jusqu'aux yeux mais pour
autant je subodorais et je ressentais
que c'était des jeunes du quartier que
peut-être 3h avant je je je voyais et et
je tutoyais donc deuxème erreur je les
ai harangué en disant maintenant on
arrête les conneries que n'aije dis là
puisque dans la demi-seonde évidemment
ils m'ont reconnu là j'ai eu des tirs de
mortiers à bout portant euh sur ma
personne hors voiture donc j'étais donc
sorti à boutportant ce qui nous a fait
craindre d'ailleurs que j'ai un pant
touché
puisque je n'entendais pas grand-chose
pendant les quelques minutes qui ont
suivi j'ai juste eu le temps de de de
mettre à l'abri dans la voiture et euh
grâce à ma voiture finalement de
m'extraire en faisant une marche arrière
de de de près de 200 m euh pour
m'extraire de de de ce de ce guetapan
euh ce qui m'a frappé c'est le terme
c'est la la mer c'est la mer on va se la
faire euh que j'ai très clairement très
clairement entendu donc il y avait aucun
doute sur sur les l'objectif ou ou la
volonté des des des assaillants si je
puis dire donc voilà un petit peu le le
le le contexte s'agissant des agressions
directes et directes et physique et puis
ensuite vous avez alors il y a eu ma
personne mais également la personne de
de personnels municipaux hors police
municipale vous aviez des agents
d'entretien des agents des service
technique qui venaient sécuriser les
écoles qui faisaient les tours qui
étaient eux-mêmes pris à parti voire
directement agressés pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'ils étaient identifiés
ville de Pontoise agents municipaux et
donc j'allais dire dans l'esprit de
cesdc rébré agents de l'État en tout cas
agent de la République et de ce fait là
était était pris pour cible j'ai un
agent de la voirie qui était dans dans
une voiture de service qui a été
attaquée à coup de marteau avec vitre
vitres brisé on a juste eu le temps de
l'extraire par un de ses un de ses
collègues et et si je dis ça
heureusement les dégâts pour le coup
physique sont sont sont son contenu sont
sont légers les dégâts psychologiques
sont beaucoup plus importants vous
l'aurez bien compris et et et durable je
veux en retirer néanmoins des éléments
positifs et c'est l'occasion pour moi
ici et je vous remercie de me donner
cette tribune là pour dire à quel point
les services municipaux et je me
contenterai de cela puisque c'est c'est
c'est sur eux que j'ai autorité euh
d'abord une un courage une vraie
solidarité et un sens du service public
qui malgré le danger était était au
rendez-vous et je je dois dire que
malgré le la peur qui nous a étreint ou
en tout cas on savait pas bien ce qui se
qui se passait la fierté que j'ai pu
avoir de de de les avoir de les avoir à
nos côtés donc ces préjudices
psychologiques sont sont là pour les
services de de la ville mais également
pour la population dans son ensemble
vous tirez aujourd'hui un feu d'artifice
en ville je vous garant ti qu'il faut
prévenir longtemps à l'avance ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais rappeler
répéter qu'il s'agit d'un événement
festif joyeux qu'il n'y a pas de danger
vous avez aujourd'hui des enfants qui
pleurent dès l'instant où on entend on
entend de la pyrotechnie tant ces trois
nuits ont été extrêmement impactantes
psychologiquement quelques conséquences
quelques conséquences juridiques qui ont
déjà été bien connu et relayés par par
la presse bon au-delà des budgets qu'il
faut déployer pour pour remettre nos
villes en
état ce sont les conséquences s'agissant
des assurances la ville de Pontoise là
encore ne fait pas exception
c'est-à-dire que l'ensemble de nos
contrats ont été dénoncés résiliés par
nos notre compagnie
d'assurance nous avons un des marchés
que nous avons réussi à conclure avec
200 % d'augmentation en terme de budget
et le le deuxième lot s'agissant cette
fois-ci donc de la respons abilité sur
les personnes et les biens qui est qui a
été infructueux et donc nous allons
essayer de négocier gréagré mais
probablement avec des conséquences
financières extrêmement extrêmement
importantes donc voilà pour le
rapidement
dresser le le jeallis dire la
photographie de ce qui s'est passé
durant ces durant ces 3 jours les
conclusions les conclusion que j'en tire
et est ce qu'on et le profil si tentait
qu'on puisse en dresser he euh d'abord
euh à Pontoise je me contente de ma
ville les ces émeutes ont été
circonscrites aux deux quartiers
prioritaires vraiment donc c'était
localisé ce qui me fait dire d'ailleurs
que c'était les hémetiers étaient des
habitants et et des jeunes en local des
locaux des locaux de l'étape comme comme
on dit
ge très jeune moi ce que j'ai pu
identifier de mes agresseurs ils avaient
entre 14 14 et 17 ans maximum c'est des
choses qui se voient ils étaient pas
formés comme des hommes vraiment c'était
des ados quoi ça c'est le ça c'est le
deuxè le deuxème point le troisème point
est-ce que c'était organisé oui et non
est-ce qu'il y avait une cause oui et
non contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire
ou entendre je ne crois pas à une
révolte dite des banlieux ou à une
révolte contre le système ou je n'y
crois pas je crois beaucoup plus un
déchaînement euh de de de de jeunes qui
ont été qui ont trouvé là une occasion
de oui bah de se déchaîner euh avec
aucune aucune prise avec la réalité ils
auraient été dans un jeu vidéo que
c'était pareil je pense que la vie
humaine les les éléments matériels rien
navait rien navait de prix mais pas même
le leur pour pour vous dire pour vous
donner un exemple eu quand quand j'ai
été agressé donc et que je me suis
réfugié dans la voiture ils ont réussi à
main nu à main nu c'est dire la force et
le délire qu'il qu'il qui les animait et
qui les habitait à main nu à brisé le
pare-brise alors sans faire de pub une
3008 c'est costaud hein euh donc on
était dans un déchaînement total et je
ne crois pas du tout donc à une démarche
qui défendait une idéologie une cause
quelconque
euh je le crois vraiment sincèrement en
revanche euh que nous ayons eu euh
j'allais dire des des des représentants
de céta
territoir sur lesquels nous avons de
moins en moins de prise à savoir les
points de d'Ille et les quartiers qui
sont gangréné par le trafic de drogue la
réponse est oui et si il y a eu une
organisation et une coordination c'est
précisément par ces personnes alors qui
sont même pas les dealers he pour le
coup qui sont les organisateurs de
réseau qui là pour le coup oui étit à la
manœuvre pour coordonner tous ces jeunes
qui sont leur pardon du terme entre
guillemets leur Chouf leur revendeurs et
et cetera et cetera leur réseau euh et
c'est c'était eux qui étaient à la
manœuvre j'ai j'ai j'en ai entre
guillemets la la la démonstration ou à
tout le moins l'intuition profonde
puisque lorsque nous avons fait comme
toutes les villes de France euh la la la
la prise de parole hein sur les sur les
parvies de nos nos villes le lundi de
mémoire à midi j'ai bien identifié
moi-même à titre personnel hein de visu
deux deux individus bien connus services
comme on dit qui sont réputés pour être
des têtes de réseau et qui étaient là
pour écouter ce que l'on disait moi-même
le directeur de cabinet du préfet pour
éventuellement anticiper et et prendre
les mesures pour tenir leur leur
territoire c'était c'était absolument
absolument flagrant euh et et et j'en
viens là sur on peut dire j'en dirais
quelques mots mais on peut énumérer un
certain nombre de mesures on a parlé de
l'école on a parlé de la sécurité on a
parlé des médiateurs tout ça très bien
je pourrais je pourrai un peu plus les
détailler le sujet dans ces quartiers
c'est le trafic de drogue c'est c'est le
seul et unique sujet parce que vous
pouvez faire prendre toutes les mesures
que vous voulez pour l'éducation prendre
toutes les mesures que vous voulez pour
la politique de la ville prendre toutes
les mesures que vous voulez en matière
de sport si les trafics de drogue
organisés structurés avec des Manes
financières sans limite
perdur nous ne parviendrons pas à
reprendre prise et reprendre pied dans
ces quartiers et ces émeutes c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé parce que
je vous rappelle qu'elles ont démarré en
appuyant sur un bouton elles ont cessé
en appuyant sur un bouton du jour en
lendemain en une seconde de manière
totalement coordonnée sans sans
complètement le sans complètement que ce
le soit à l'échelle nationale de manière
volontaire en tout cas mais pour une
bonne et simple raison c'était les
points de deal sur lesquels il y avait
ces attaques le commerce a été
interrompu pendant 3 jours et 3 nuits ou
en tout cas au moins 3 nuits euh et que
je pense que donc les responsables de de
ces de ces points ont estimé que le
commerce pardon le dire comme ça avait
trop souffert et qu'il était temps de
repasser aux affaires sérieuses si je
puis dire vous aurez bien compris que je
suis ironique en disant en disant cela
une question madame le Maire pouvez
rappeler à l'assistance la taille de
votre commune bientôt 4000 habitants
donc région parisienne bientôt 40000
dans le valdoise oui dans le valdoise
voilà je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur arot puis on reviendra vers
vous après bien sûr alors Monsieur
olivia rogot est le maire de Charle
commune du rô bonjour merci monsieur le
président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs je je vous remercie tout
d'abord de pour votre invitation qui
témoigne de l'attention que vous portez
à à cette problématique de violence à
l'égard des élus et et en particulier
envers les maires c'est un sujet
récurrent qui malheureusement est à
nouveau au devant de des projecteurs
cette année suite aux épisodes de
violence urbaine de l'été dernier euh je
suis donc le maire de la ville de
Charlie 5000 habitants dans le Sud-Ouest
de la métropole de Lyon une commune qui
aurait tendance à être qualifiée de
village puisque nous avons plutôt une
ADN un ADN pardon
agricole et ce qui m'amène aujourd'hui
ici et bien c'est une attaque
personnelle puisque le le dimanche de
juillet une torche enflammée a été jetée
sur ma maison bien heureusement sans
sans dégâts autres euh nous n'avons pas
été touchés euh sur l'ensemble de nos
bâtiments bien heureusement nos voisins
l'ont été mais pas la commune de Charlie
donc pour revenir un peu sur les faits
euh le dimanche de juillet je je
célébrais les l'anniversaire de ma jeune
sœur en famille à la maison et et mon
voisin a découvert une torche qui avait
consumé euh devant mon portail et euh
m'en a informé alors c'est vrai que sur
le coup j'ai pas prêté trop d'attention
puisque j'étais plutôt dans les
préparatifs familiaux et puis finalement
j'ai quand même contacté les gendarmes
qui sont venus et j'ai commencé à
prendre conscience de l'acte qui était
qui avait été réalisé c'est-à-dire que
ce qui avait fait que j'avais pas trop
prêté attention c'est que la torche
était tombée du bon côté du portail et
et avait consumé toute seule dans son
coin de l'autre côté du portail il y
avait évidemment une pelouse des
arbustes nos différents véhicules
familiaux et puis surtout j'ai pris
conscience que euh c'était contrairement
au bâtiment public on attaquait la
personne et j'ai commencé à avoir peur
pour ma famille mon épouse et mes
enfants donc la procédure a été bien sûr
entamée par les gendarmes des
prélèvements ADN ont été faits de l'ADN
a été trouvé malheureusement la personne
n'est actuellement pas fichée donc le
l'enquête se se poursuit
mais c'est un c'est c'est vraiment le le
basculement sur l'attaque person et plus
uniquement les institutions
alors depuis malheureusement ça n'est
pas la la
seule violence qu'on a qu'on a subi à
Charlie pour aller très rapidement mais
en 2021 lorsque nous avions rendu homage
à Samuel paatti j'avais reçu des menaces
des menaces de mort sur internet par un
groupe islamiste qui qui a été
identifié j'ai ensuite vécu dans les
jours qu'on suivi des des agressions
verbales sur la place de la mairie un
dimanche après-midi on est on est
souvent quand on est maire on aime bien
retourner en mairie le dimanche pour
préparer un peu la semaine et et et donc
je me suis présenté plutôt en tenue de
weekend on va dire c'est-à-dire sans
éléments qui pourrait nous nous
identifier c'est-à-dire pas de costume
pas de cravate dit façon un peu plus
légère et et une bande de jeune de loin
évidemment
euh m'ont proposé d'aller me faire
le maire pour vous partager ces
ces bons moments un de mes adjoints a
lui aussi été malheureusement victime
d'insulte homophobe devant son domicile
et évidemment je vous passe l'ensemble
des dégradations du mobilier urbain
comme nous l'avons tous avec des croix
gamé des NTM le le maire et cetera et
cetera donc l'ensemble de ces agressions
et de ces
dégradations interroge évidemment sur
l'ensemble des relations qu'on eu petite
partie de notre population vis-à-vis euh
des institutions alors pour aller un peu
dans dans la réflexion euh nous avons
l'impression d'être spectateur de
d'individus qui sont provocateurs qui
sont convaincus d'une certaine impunité
euh convaincu que finalement rien ne
peut leur arriver j'ai le sentiment
aussi de certains jeunes qui n'ont pas
conscience parfois de la gravité de
leurs actes est-ce un manque d'éducation
est-ce un manque de fermeté ou de limite
qu'ils auraient dans la sphère privée
scolaire je ressens en tout cas une
disparition de la notion d'autorité
qu'elle soit scolaire institutionnelle
ou ou politique disons plus généralement
une disparition du
respect dans le rapport entre les
individus j'ai l'impression d'assister
aussi à une certaine désinhibition du
comportement dont nous les maires bien
nous sommes les les victimes les cibles
n'importe qui peut être touché n'importe
quand et je crois que il faut en prendre
conscience je partage l'avis de mes
collègues qui indiquent que certains
citoyens exercent de plus en plus de
pression sur les élus et en particulier
sur nous qui constituons ce premier
échelon
politique le problème n'est pas la
pression ou la mobilisation ou
l'opposition qui peut être au contraire
saine et et témoigner d'un B un bon état
démocratique le problème est
l'expression violente des Brid sans
fondement la contestation le dénigrement
systématique les attaques et les
accusations personnelles que nous que
nous subissons j'ai le sentiment d'une
absence de limite d'une intolérance à la
frustration lorsque l'on pose ou fait
appliquer des règles règles qui bien
souvent nous dépassent et ne sont pas de
notre fait cela renvoie à un autre sujet
qui contribue je pense au mal-être des
mères c'est le sentiment d'être seul
face à cela et même fragilisé et
affaibli par certaines décision
législative qui contribue à réduire nos
marges de manœuvre à diminuer nos
recettes à nous obliger à appliquer des
décisions parfois impopulaires ou encore
complexifier notre quotidien par un
millefeuille administratif et des
risques juridiques du coup importants
qui pèsent sur nos épaules la fonction
de maire je dis fonction parce que nous
ne sommes ni formés ni réell accompagné
dans cet exercice devient de plus en
plus
dissuasif en nous engageant nous le
faisons sur le plan professionnel avec
les conséquences que cela peut avoir sur
nos métiers initiaux nous le faisons sur
le plan personnel et on l'a bien vu cet
été avec à la fois des sacrifices ou des
atteintes familiales que tout le monde
connaît ici sur le plan juridique aussi
avec des règles au nombre et à la
complexité croissante et qui font peser
sur nos épaules le risque permanent de
la responsabilité mais aussi et enfin de
plus en plus sur le plan sécuritaire
avec des menaces et des attaques
individuelles et familiales
croissant alors effectivement votre
travail parlementaire est important
parce que même si les voocation pour
devenir mère persiste il faut malgré
tout enrayer ce phénomène c'est à mon
sens un problème sociétal qui dépasse
bien largement la seule situation des
élus locaux ce n'est qu'un qu'un
symptôme évidemment il est à noter que
nombre de ces attaques que nous
subissons ne sont parfois pas le fait de
nos propres administrés mais d'individus
militants pour certaines causes et qui
sembleent très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux et les réseaux pétitionnaires
internet et les réseaux sociaux sont
clairement un catalyseur de cette
violence à la guerre des élus symptôme
d'un déchaînement de violence de
l'irrespect à l'égard des figures de
l'autorité ou du pouvoir autrement dit
tous ceux qui exirent tous ceux qui
exercent une autorité ou disposent d'une
légitimité sont haï ou combatttu et
cette haine et ce rejet sont encore plus
vif lorsqu'il s'agit de figures
associées à la République je pense aux
instituteurs aux professeurs au médecins
aux infirmières aux soignants pompiers
policiers gendarmes juges avocats j'en
oublie évidemment mais tous sont aussi
victimes de ce dénigrement et d'attaque
personnel la médiatisation de la
polémique met le Ballau sur des
individus considérés à ce moment-là
comme responsable à qui l'on va chercher
des liens des intérêts cachés et ces
démarches malveillantes aboutissent à
des actes de violence comme forme de
punition ou d'actes ou d'opinion qu'on
leur attribue sans aucun fondement alors
face à cela la réponse n'est peut-être
pas assez ferme aujourd'hui mais nous
avons vu qu'elle a été un petit peu plus
dans le droit commun lors des épisodes
de violence urbaine de l'été dernier
je crois surtout que c'est dans la
prévention que nous devons agir car
lorsque l'acte est commis c'est déjà
trop tard et nous devons être vigilant à
à cette à ce phénomène de de vengeance
la prévention c'est l'éducation des
parents l'école républicaine avec un
enseignement de qualité et la
méritocratie il faut également en
parallèle et j'en arriverai à la fin de
mon propos arrêter avec ce que je
qualifierai de cult de
l'excuse le fait de de tolérer ou d'être
complaisant à l'égard des problèmes
d'incivilité ou de violence que ce soit
dans la sphère familiale scolaire publi
favorise et bien cette idée selon
laquelle il y a toujours une bonne
raison d'être violent je crois que cette
culture de l'excuse prend différentes
formes et traduit un manque de courage
parfois ou une forme de complaisance qui
ne pose pas de limite aux individus et
créerait finalement un droit à la
délinquence c'est ce qui conduit à
laisser persister des problèmes de
harcèlement dans certains établissements
scolaires ou sanctionner un enseignement
comme Samuel paatti qui s'est retrouvé
finalement bien seul et vulnérable face
à ses bourreaux potentiels c'est
peut-être aussi la complaisance dans les
débats médiatiques ou académiques ne
serait-ce qu'à propos du sujet des
émeutes pour lesquels je rappelle que
quelques élus et commentateurs ont
trouvé des motivations politiques et des
raisons social légitime aux agressions
des élus et aux dégradations des biens
publics c'est l'exemple même de la
culture de l'excuse et d'ailleurs j'ai
pu écouter la sociologue Nathalie enich
qui est intervenue ici même à propos des
émeutes et je la rejoins non seulement
sur son propos concernant la
décivilisation mais également quand elle
parle et cela vient vient expliquer ce
que je viens de dire quand elle parle de
la complaisance de certains de ces
collègues confrères qui tendent à
légitimer des actes de violence et de
destruction de biens publics jusqu'à
même ne pas les dénoncer alors je crois
qu'il y a une responsabilité
individuelle et collective à dénoncer
tout cela nous avons besoin de l'État et
de ses institutions pour faire respecter
les principes et les valeurs qui sont
les seules à rendre possible le vivre
ensemble plus de moyens financiers et
humains pour nos services municipaux nos
polices municipales qui ont énormément
vré cet été des moyens humains et
financiers pour le renseignement afin
d'agir en amont pour la justice pour
qu'elle soit ferme et appliquée pour
l'éducation qui reste le socle du vivre
ensemble pour l'accompagnement social
pour ne pas oublier nos concitoyens en
difficulté bien sûr une aide importante
de l'État dans le cadre de la maîtrise
de la couverture assurentiel ma collègue
maire vient d'en parler puisque ça
devient un réel problème avec des coûts
exorbitants et parf fois même
l'impossibilité de s'assurer et puis
revenons à la présence accrue des
institutions sur le terrain j'ai fait un
petit focus sur les réseaux Internet
parce que j'ai pu constater suite à à à
ma menace de mort que il y avait un
délai de prescription sur les menaces
qui est de 3 mois et et ce ce délai
évidemment semble un peu court parfois
alors voilà je je vais en conclure pour
dire que toutes ces mesures doivent être
évidemment mises en œuvre approfondies
c'est une nécessité pour nous et pour
l'avenir de notre société parce que c de
la démocratie de proximité dont il
s'agit nous sommes le premier échelon et
avons besoin de tout le soutien de
l'État car sous une certaine façon nous
nous incarnons les institutions
politiques je vous remercie pour votre
attention et vous remercie à nouveau
pour le travail que vous faites pour
nous merci merci Monsieur le Maire pour
votre intervention je propose de donner
la parole à Monsieur
De Carli qui est en visio et puis
ensuite Monsieur François qui est arrivé
il y a quelques instants monsieur de
Carly vous êtes le maire de
montsain-martin en Meur etuselle vous
avez la parole oui merci monsieur le
Président et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de votre invitation à laquelle
je réponds bien volontiers comme je l'ai
d'ailleurs fait pour l'Assemblée
nationale puisque j'étaé auditionné par
une commission à l'Assemblée nationale
également donc Serge decli donc je suis
euh un fruit un pur fruit de de la
République puisque 4e génération issue
de l'immigration italienne mon AR
grand-père ayant fut le fascisme italien
et cétait en réfugié effectivement en
France en Lorine mon grand-père était
mineur voilà euh donc des gens qui ont
travaillé dur et euh j'ai essayé de
rendre à la République ce qu'elle a
donné à ma famille en devenant
instituteur directeur d'école professeur
des écoles j'ai terminé ma carrière il y
a il y a quelques mois le 1er septembre
et euh je suis élu depuis
1989 j'ai été adjoint 3 ans 1er adjoint
12 ans et ça fait une vingtaine d'années
que je suis maire je suis également
conseiller général départemental c'est
mon 3e mandat depuis 2008 et je suis
président de l'agglomération du Grand
longoui 63000 habitants 21 communes la
2è agglomération de Meurth et Mosel
après le Grand Nancy mont-sain-martin
10000 habitants une ville comme il en
existe peu puisque ça s'appelle la ville
au trois frontières à 500 m il y a la
frontière belge et la frontière
luxembourgeoise il y a ce qu'on appelle
le point triple avec ses avantages et
ses inconvénients évidemment une ville
populaire avec un quartier de 4500
habitants où se trouve la mairie
actuellement je ne suis pas dans mon
bureau parce que j'ai pas de bureau
depuis le mois de juillet
euh je vous expliquerai pourquoi et donc
une ville où il y a un qpv de 4500
habitants quartier politique de la ville
un réseau d'éducation prioritaire
h écoles un collège bientôt un collège
neuf euh un budget annuel investissement
fonctionnement de 12 millions d'euros
quand la ville voisine de Pétange
Luxembourg c'est 120 millions
et une richesse moyenne annuelle par
foyer à mont-sain-martin de 9800 €. vous
ferez le calcul c'est 830 € par mois et
là-dedans vous avez 30 % de frontaliers
qui gagnent à EU2 entre 8 et 10000 €
donc euh des politiques municipales de
solidarité énorme 1 million d'euros dans
dans les solidarités une épisserie
sociale pour permettre aux gens de de
vivre une régie de quartier pour
l'insertion professionnelle euh des
éducateurs de rueah voilà de manière
très très très générale et très rapide
donc une ville à laquelle je tiens une
ville bah qui vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi à sorti un champion
olympique de karaté triple champion du
monde encore récemment je l'ai eu comme
élève euh qui a de grands succès euh
mais qui a été touché comme peu euh par
ce qu'on a appelé les émeutes puisque
cette ville de 10000 habitants a vu neuf
bâtiments publics saccagés incendiés
dégradé euh les événements ont commencé
dans la nuit du 27 au 28 juin avec un un
outil rare le cessade vivre avec
l'autisme donc un outil d'aide aux
enfants handicapés touchés par l'autisme
mais aussi accompagnement aux familles
qui travaill en lien avec un centre
d'action médico-social précoce un camps
posé à montsain-martin parce que nous
sommes une ville très structurée j'y
reviendrai et donc cet outil a été le
premier à à brûler complètement dans la
nuit du 27 au 28 juin nous sommes une
ville très vidéo protégée la première du
département également 70 caméras donc
nous avons visionné bien évidemment les
bandes vidéo et on voit trois jeunes
trois jeunes euh en puchonné assis sur
un banc bon assez oisif la nuit il y en
a un qui se lève à un moment donné avec
une bouteille à la main donc la cocktail
Molotov qui met qui incendie le bâtiment
qui se rassé pour pour observer ce qui
se passe donc voilà sur cet événement-
là euh ensuite la nuit donc c'est 500000
€ qui sont partis en en fumée la nuit
suivante c'est une école maternelle qui
a été attaquée euh la buvette du club de
foot le club houseous du club de foot
euh et dans la même nuit nous a eu nous
avons eu sans que je le sache
l'intervention du Raid on aurait pu
avoir une deuxième affaire comme un
entire et le jeune emen Baou a été
touché par un flashball euh il a fait un
mois de coma il a failli mourir il est
handicapé il s'en est sorti et je je je
dois vous dire que ce n'est pas un
hémetier c'est un jeune garçon qui
rentrait de son travail euh puisqu'il
est frontalier travaille au Luxembourg
jeune de 25 ans donc une enquête est en
cours moi je n'ai pas de nouvelles à ce
sujet en tout cas le jeune est sorti
d'affaire mais il restera handicapé il a
été opéré à plusieurs reprise et
j'attends de de le revoir en tout cas
voilà sur cette affaire
euh la nuit ensuite du 30 juin au 1er
juillet c'est l'hôtel de ville qui a été
attaqué saccagé et il n'en est pas
encore remis j'avais annoncé à l'époque
que la Marie était morte
et voyez je suis dans un je pourrais
montrer il y a des cartons en corore il
a des cartons dans mon garage de mon
domicile mon bureau n'est n'est toujours
pas refait nous avons remis en selle
immédiatement d'abord les services de la
Ville ne se sont jamais arrêtés
peut-être de jours euh puisque nous
avons l'état civil de l'agglomération
nous avons un hôpital sur la ville de
montsain-martin qui est l'hôpital de de
de tout un secteur la Meuse est toute
proche et euh bien évidemment vous
imaginez le travail administratif porté
par ce service donc c'est le premier
service que nous avons réouvert dans la
mairie nous avons nous avons comment
dirais-je disséminé pendant pendant
plusieurs mois l'ensemble des services
de la ville sur sur quatre ou CIN sites
différents la ville fait 45 km de voiri
donc un travail extrêmement difficile on
s'était réfugié dans la médiathèque de
la commune on campait enfin voilà c'est
c'est c'est une une affaire très très
lourde en tout cas psychologiquement
puisque il a fallu recevoir l'ensemble
des AG gens on a fait un travail avec un
psychologue enfin ça a été très très
compliqué euh dire aussi que à titre
personnel quelques maires ont subi ça
mais j'en fais partie euh dans la nuit
du 1er au au 2 juillet il a fallu que je
m'enfuie de mon domicile avec mon épouse
pour être exfiltré me retrouver dans un
hôtel au Luxembourg proche euh Monsieur
le Préfet de martemoiselle m'avait
téléphoné mais j'avais aussi reçu un
certain nombre d'appels téléphoniques
dans la journée
du 1er juillet pour m'indiquer qu'il
était plus prudent que je ne reste pas à
mon domicile puisque j'étais visé
certains jeunes considérant que si leur
aide était venu sur ma commune c'était
la demande du maire et que ce qui
s'était passé était de mon fait donc
bien évidemment il en est rien vous le
savez le pouvoirs de police en France
c'est le préfet qui qui l'exerce qui
choisit on a un département qui est si
vous le connaissez c'est a l'histoire de
France il est très très très allongé
c'est ça ressemble canard et nous sommes
dans la tête du canard donc très éloigné
de Nancy où je vais régulièrement au
conseil départemental à 125 km d'ici et
donc c'est il a une intervention du raid
il s'est passé ce qui s'est passé mais
en tout cas je n'y étais évidemment pour
rien je suis revenu à la demande de mon
épouse nous avons réintégré notre maison
alors qu'on souhaitait que nous restions
à l'extérieur pendant plusieurs nuits
nous sommes rentrés le 2 juillet dans
notre maison parce que c'est notre seul
bien il nous appartient c'est notre vie
notre histoire et et j'ai eu pendant
c'était un dimanche toute la journée
enfin l'après-midi complète en tout cas
la
gendarmerie très complaisante
bienveillante à nos côtés pour vérifier
le caractère sécuritaire de la maison
nous avons remplacer une porte de mon
domicile de notre domicile hier elle est
elle est très sécurisée mais en tout cas
il y avait une porte à sécuriser on nous
a placé des caméras pendant 2 mois tout
le mois de juillet tout le mois d'août y
compris lorsque nous étions en vacances
avec des des vues directes sur sur les
iPhones et la gendarmerie éta en
capacité de d'agir ce que j'ai oublié
dire c'est quand on réintègre notre
domicile pendant 3 qu nuits nous avons
eu h gendarmes en armes dans deux
véhicules différents positionnés pas
très loin de notre domicile pour veiller
à notre sécurité donc quelque chose
d'assez traumatisant al pour moi-même et
surtout pour ma compagne qui qui n'a pas
mérité ça enfin voilà moi non plus mais
en tout cas voilà donc euh euh une une
période très bouleversante très
traumatisante don je ne suis pas encore
remis sur le plan psychologique je dois
vous le dire euh il m'a traversé l'idée
pendant quelques instants d'abandonner
mais quelques brefs instants j'ai donné
un certain nombre d'entretien
d'interview à des médias nombreuses et
variés dont BFM euh et euh j'ai entendu
mes collègues je partage pas mal de
leurs analyses néanmoins je ne pratique
nullement la la culture de l'excuse je
vous ai dit que j'étais enseignant à la
base mais j'essaie de comprendre et et
je pense que cette période elle doit
mériter qu'on s'arrête dessus parce que
je pense que ça se reproduira si on ne
répond pas correctement et répondre
correctement moi je prends l'exemple de
ma commune je pense que les les sources
viennent de loin de très loin sur les 30
dernières années moi j'ai vu se déliter
petit à petit l'état l'état local je
veux parler des services qui assure la
cohésion des territoires et des
populations nous avons un hôpital je
vous parle du Luxembourg le Luxembourg
est la pompe aspirante de
toute les compétences formées en France
y compris les enseignants aujourd'hui et
les infirmières les médecins sont de
l'autre côté de la frontière pour des
raisons évidentes puisque vous faites
deux fois et demi votre salaire au
Luxembourg vous poser questions à l'état
d'ailleurs je parle des parlementaires
sur des choses qui existent dans le
canton jeune voie sur la ce qu'on
appelle la rétrocession fiscale d'une
toute petite partie des impôts prélevé
sur les salaires des frontaliers qui
rapporte beaucoup et bien au à l'ami
voisin le Luxembourg que je ne critique
pas mais en tout cas il y a quelque
chose à faire on assiste à une
paupérisation à la frontière française
et un enrichissement de l'autre côté et
un jour ça ça cessera tout cela donc
dire qu'effectivement depuis trop
longtemps nos services publics vont mal
l'école va mal on remplace plus les
maîtres je suis bien placé pour le
savoir les derniers mois que j'ai
effectué la test nous avons une poste
qui a été attaquée alors qui n'a rien à
voir avec les émeutes mais qui a été
attaqué à l'explosif au mois de mars
2022 donc ça fera 2 ans bientôt elle
sera réouverte en février suite à
l'intervention de l'État déconcentré
madame le préfet que je
félicite pour son soutien défectible le
sous-préfet les services de l'État
déconcentrés agissent vraiment à nos
côtés et de manière très très forte et
bienveillante et jeen remercie j'en suis
reconnaissant mais en tout cas cette
poste qui est la plus grosse poste de
l'agglomération était fermé depuis
bientôt 2 ans c'est un service de
proximité avec des populations en grande
difficulté qui en ont grand besoin joue
un rôle social donc elle sera réouverte
mais ça sera fera bientôt 2 ans je je
parle d'un hôtel de police et je loue le
travail de la police républicaine dans
ce pays qui qui est courageuse et qui
est à nos côtés mais dans notre hôtel de
police il manque un/ers des effectifs et
quand je parle des renforts ça vient de
Nancy donc et 25 km ça compte je pe pas
parler des transports on peut parler
donc de la poche l'évoqué de l'hôpital
donc les infirmiers les médecins nous
sommes en zone de désertification
médicale et moi ce que je mesure c'est
qu'il y a un sentiment fondé ou infondé
mais d'une forme d'oubli d'abandon de
certaines populations et qui bah à
certains moment alors effectivement il y
a des prétextes ça c'était passé en 2005
déjà ici en 2007 également ça se
renouvelle le prétexte c'est
effectivement un événement à échelle
nationale qui qui est médiatisé les
réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle énorme et
on en arrive là donc bien évidemment la
violence n'apporte jamais rien sinon de
la violence et des restrictions de
liberté de toute manière toujours ça se
soit dans tous les pays du monde et je
sais ce dont je ce dont je veux parler
donc c'est pas du tout ce que je
préconise en tout cas je pense que les
réponses ne peuvent pas être uniquement
sécuritaires et autoritaire on parle de
la responsabilisation des familles j'en
suis d'accord néanmoins je constate ici
beaucoup de familles monoparentales des
mamans vant seul des enfants qui
deviennent adolescents et qui vont
travailler nitamment au Luxembourg par
exemple prennent des transports en
commun pour des lignes transfrontalières
pour aller travailler à luxembourgville
dans des bureaux nuitamant laissant
leurs enfants à la maison que font leurs
enfants voilà c'est un sujet et donc il
y a tout le travail d'éducation
populaire de prévention effectivement à
mener àorter qui qui va pas bien dans ce
pays donc on en est là donc voilà un
petit petit peu avoir j'ai brossé tout
cela vous dire que on est la seule ville
euh me semble-t-il de France à avoir eu
en lien avec les émeutes un bâtiment
attaqué en dehors du 5 juillet puisque
nationalement on a considéré que la date
du 5 juillet était la date de fin des
émeutes puisque dans la nuit du 13 au 14
juillet nous n'avons pas fait de de feu
d'artifice pas fait de fête on a fait
une un rassemblement républicain auquel
ont participai des parlementaires
monsieur le sous-préfet on a fait la
fête dans un parc municipal en journée
avec mes agents avec les la population
les associations ça s'est très bien
passé et dans la nuit du 13 au 14
juillet on a la plus grosse école de la
ville située en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire 200 élèves qui a été attaqué
brûlé incendié saccagé et euh donc qui
était également morte et nous avons
relevé le défi euh puisque c'était un
weekend je me souvient très bien donc le
samedi matin on a constaté les dégâts
mais mes agents sont venus mon directeur
service technique et de l'Urbanisme
lundi les assurances étaient les experts
étaient sur place et le mardi SEP
entreprise local étaient là avec nos
services et nous avons engagé les
travaux de telle manière que de manière
comment dirais-je correcte digne l'école
soir réouverte le 4 septembre et ça a
été chose faite à cette heure les
réparations ne sont pas encore achevées
elles le seront lors des prochaines
vacances de Noël mais en tout cas on a
fait ce qu'il fallait et la commune et
les services l'ont fait comme ils le
font toujours pour assurer le lien avec
la population la population globalement
majoritairement N a absolument pour rien
quant aux origines comme je vous l'ai
dit on a des on a des traces on a des
vidéos toutes les pièces ont été données
à la police et à la justice Madame le
Procureur de Briet est au courant euh je
puis dire que les publics concernés sont
totalement différents j'ai évoqué le
cessad il s'agit de trois jeunes l'école
on voit aussi la vidéo euh il s'agit de
deux jeunes concernant la mairie c'est
un commando d'une cinquantaine de
personnes qui venaent de Belgique qui
venaent de Moselle et qui venaient de la
ville de villerrue toute proche et des
adultes des des des gens de 25 à 30 ans
et contrairement à ce qui était dit tout
à l'heure moi j'y vois des dessins
d'ordre politique il y a pas besoin de
faire campagne électorale on sait très
bien ce que ça engrange et et vers quoi
ça on s'achemine donc je tiens à le dire
parce que je l'ai dit d'ailleurs à à
Madame le préfet euh il y a des vidéos
qui la testent euh des hommes qui
avaient pris des substances torsenu
c'était horrible on m'a interdit de
sortir d'ailleurs de mon domicile il y
avait des sabres japonais il fallait pas
se promener dans les rues c'est
excessivement dangereux mais donc euh on
en est là concernant l'enquête je tiens
à le dire à à des parlementaires je suis
assez frustré parce que je n'ai aucun
retour et je ne peux pas imaginer que
sur une ville de 10000 habitants trouve
pas un individu à condamner parce que je
défends la prévention mais la sanction
fait partie de l'éducation et il faut
des sanctions il faut des exemples
évidemment et donc j'attends des des
résultats donc j'espère que nous en aons
et puis a été évoqué la question
assurentielle qui pour moi
est est est très très un souci énorme un
cauchemar groupam est notre assureur en
France il y a deux groupes c'est smal et
groupam qui ont quasiment situation de
monopole à l'égard des collectivités
territoriales group il l'ensemble de nos
contrats dès la première semaine du mois
d'août par pour y recommander on a
appris cela
euh j'ai bien évidemment beaucoup bougé
je suis allé deux fois à l'Élysée je
suis allé à Berille je suis allé à la
NCT madame Dominique fort est venu nous
voir et je la remercie on a eu un retour
quant à l'aide financière de l'État qui
sera important mais
néanmoins concernant Groupama à l'heure
où je vous parle 3 millions plus de 3
millions d'euros de GS nous avons engagé
notre budget propre sur ces questions
évidemment donc on a notre budget
primitif n'est pas du tout rentrer dans
la vie il y a aucun travaux de voir ou
autres qui ont été réalisés j'ai oublié
de dire 70 véhicules de particulier
brûlé sur la ville également des voiries
nombreuses abîmées et nous avons une
trésorerie habituellement fond de
roulement d'un mlion2 nous sommes à
400000 € et il y a 150 agents dans cette
ville à rémunérer donc beaucoup
d'angoisse pour le maire que je suis
mais on tient
euh je l'ai dit les services de l'État
sont là j'ai vu le président de la
République lors du congrès des maires
j'étais à la réception à l'Élysée j'ai
eu à m'exprimer avec lui jeen remercie
euh j'ai des retours là-dessus mais en
tout cas la question assurencielle est
est mortifère puisque nous avons obtenu
une dérogation de 6 mois de prorogation
de notre contrat dans les mêmes
conditions jusqu'au 1er juillet 2024 au
2 juillet contrairement à ce qui avit
été dit au départ group se propose de
nous faire une une de nous proposer un
contrat nouveau mais on sait très bien
ce qui ce qui peut en être avec des
cotisations trop élevées des services
àoindri ou des comme une collègue
maire a eu cette proposition des
franchises à 2 million d'euros ce qui
serait totalement inacceptable et
ingérable évidemment donc ça c'est un
énorme souci euh que je tiens que je
tiens à à signaler devant vous
euh et puis ajouter
encore j'avais eu à le
dire la collègue maire madame le maire
l'a dit tout à l'heure le collègue maire
l'a dit aussi en république d'abord je
suis président d'Interco les interc sont
le fruit du législateur la commune elle
est le fruit de l'histoire l'histoire de
France comme les canton sont le fruit de
l'histoire de France donc je suis
enseignant j'y tiens beaucoup
et la commune quoi qu'on en fasse même
sur l' dit vitalise au service au
bénéfice de l'interpo parfois et bien
c'est à elle qu'on s'adresse toujours
pour tous les problèmes de la vie pour
tous les problèmes de la vie et lors des
différentes étapes douloureuses que nous
avons traversé depuis 2020 parce que
c'est mon 4e mandat de mer mais comme
mes collègues c'est le plus terrible on
n'a jamais connu une période aussi
catastrophique de crise en crise que
nous avons traversé et bien ces crises
ont attesté en en tout cas quelque chose
de très important temps c'est qu'en
République et bien ce sont les communes
qui tiennent le pays elles l'ont prouvé
tout le temps lors du covid la
distribution des médicamament
l'attention portée aux personnes âgées
et encore une fois lors des émeutes
puisque malgré tout ce qui s'est passé
nous avons tenu bon on s'est débrouillé
comme on sait le faire pour assurer la
la pérennité des services publics de
proximité j'ai parlais deétat civil je
peux parler du CCAS et et de l'action
portée au plus faible en tout cas on
continue ue à le faire et donc moi ce
que je veux relever c'est que les les
élus locaux ont besoin d'un statut d'un
statut réel qui les protège je parle pas
forcément des
indemnités même si elles elles sont très
loin
effectivement de répondre au moi j'ai dû
prolonger ma carrière j'ai fini à 63 ans
une carrière
d'enseignant alors j'aurais dû prendre
une retraite même bien avant mais un
mi-temps m'a obligé à à prolonger tout
en menant compromitamment mes fonctions
électives que je fais depuis des années
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que je considère que la commune
elle joue un rôle excessivement
important dans dans dans ce pays et dans
dans la ré merci Monsieur le Maire pour
pour ce cette intervention et ce
témoignage qui révèle au moins deux
enfin il y a beaucoup de choses mais
deux singulières le problème des
relations avec le parquet sur les
informations suite aux émeutes et la
problématique assurencielle on y
reviendra sans doute indépendamment de
tout le reste que vous vous a évoqué qui
est particulièrement important don la
parole à Monsieur Emmanuel François qui
est le maire de Saint-Pierre descor je
rappelle que Saint-Pierre descor c'est
en indr etloir pour la géographie
générale mais tout le monde le sait vous
avez la parole il est
10h58 15 minutes 15 20 minutes parce que
les collègues vont vouloir poser des
questions et si on veut tenir dans le
timing il faut que on soit ainsi surtout
pour les questions en fait c'est
important Monsieur François vous avez la
parole merci monsieur monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues ému par
votre intervention monsieur decly nous
nous étions vu lors de la commission
vous vous en souvenez la commission à
l'Assemblée nationale euh si je suis ici
c'est que j'ai été agressé plusieurs
fois euh même de nombreus fois pour
rappel puisque vous l'avez demandé tout
à l'heure monsieur le Président nous
sommes une commune de 16300 habitants 3e
4e ville du
département avec deux quartiers
prioritaires un qui vient de rentrer
dans le nouveau contrat de ville et le
l'ancien quartier prioritaire qui compte
à peu près un/ers de la population et
qui se situe de manière assez singulière
en plein centrreeville euh les causes
qu'est-ce qu'on a dit en fait parce que
je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure je
partage ce que vous avez dit Madame le
Maire mais pas tout à fait il y a eu moi
de la population que je connais puisque
j'étais installé en tant que médecin
généraliste au cœur du quartier
prioritaire ce que j'en connais c'est
que il y a eu une espèce de rit
initiatique des jeunes un rit
initiatique qui a été provoqué pas
simplement par l'usage des drogues que
l'on connaît actuellement mais aussi par
l'utilisation d'une drogue qui est en
vente libre le protoxyde d'azote nous
avons pris d'ailleurs à la mairie de
Saint-Pierre descord un arrêté pour
interdire cette vente au mineur je crois
que c'est un problème qui commence à à à
arriver et à s'étendre un peu partout et
auquel il faut porter une attention
toute
particulière en gros il y a
effectivement une remarque sur cette
violence cette soudaineté cette cette
échappement des des des personnes qui
étaient pendant les émeutes à la réalité
et là je vous rejoins complètement j'en
avais parler avec le le Conseiller à la
Présidence de la République à l'Élysée
euh sur le fait que si on analyse les
différentes émeutes qui ont commencé dès
1968 nous avions déjà en 1968 et
j'attire toute votre attention même si
vous pouvez ne pas être d'accord nous
avions déjà de la consommation de
cannabis la consommation de cannabis
dans mon métier j'ai vu des personnes
qui ont ce qu'on appelle les syndromes
paranoïdes et qui sont capables à force
d'en consommer de se mettre 23 coups de
couteau et d'exprimer des théories du
complot sur à la fois le gouvernement ou
les gens qui les entourent de manière
tout à fait pnass donc ça c'est une
chose importante euh attendez je
reprends un tout petit peu mes pour voir
ce que pour pas oublier quoi que ce soit
euh je voudrais revenir sur il y a il y
a le trafic de drogue mais pas seulement
puisqu'on s'est aperçu quand même que
dans les émeutes et surtout dans le
milieu rural il y avait pas forcément un
trafic de drotte mais plutôt et c'est là
où je rejoins monsieur de Carly plutôt
une influence politique alors les
allégations sur tel ou tel parti qui
influencerait peut-être ce genre
d'émeutes moi j'ai envie de vous dire ça
m'a intéresse pas d'abord je ne peux
plus supporter les partis politiques ne
vous et j'en j'en parlais justement à
mon collègue à côté je ne peux plus
supporter ce qu'ont fait les partis
politiques depuis des années et ont
laissé une France dans un état tout à
fait pitoyable et j'en ai j'en ai
vraiment beaucoup de peine
[Musique]
h
alors je soulligne aussi la solidarité
qu'il y a eu parce que vous avez eu
raison d'exprimer ça c'est-à-dire qu'à
la fin à la fin des émeutes
le matin quand on était quand on est
arrivé et qu'on a offert les croissants
au pompiers qui venaient de l'ensemble
du département pour essayer de contenir
les incendies multiples et variés
puisque nous avons 15 bâtiments touchés
dont la bibliothèque une galerie
d'exposition des gymnases des commerce
les pharmacies la mairie et j'en passe
la salle des fêtes enfin il y a il y a
vraiment cette solidarité a été
extrêmement importante à la fois
départementale on l'a remarqué aussi
dans nos services quand il a fallu
prendre des mesures c'est-à-dire qu'on
avait des personnes qui étaient là et
qui euh avec les associations le milieu
associatif le lycée professionnel pour
colmater les brèches ça ça a été un élan
qui je vous assure nous a fait
énormément de
bien
l'historique alors je peux pas je peux
pas ne pas vous parler des émeutes sans
vous parler de l'historique de
Saint-Pierre descord moi je suis arrivé
donc comme je vous l'ai dit médecin dans
un quartier prioritaire je regarde
l'heure hein monsieur le Président j'ess
j'ai essayé de faire moins d'un quart
d'heure et et et vous la regardez aussi
je suppose et donc dans ce quartier
prioritaire installé avec la possibilité
à la population de faire ce qu'on
appelle des consultations libres
c'estàdire pas de rendez-vous un service
rendu à la population qui est énorme
quand vous avez un nouveau né qui a 42
fièvres et que vous devez le coucher
dans la soirée sans qu'il soit vu par un
médecin et vous savez pas ce qui se
passe la population avait la possibilité
de venir même si c'était à 9h 9h30 du
soir venir faire soigner son enfant
après une attente peut-être dans la
salle d'attente de plus de 3 He mais au
moins une certitude que le travail a été
fait et que le service a été rendu nous
avons donc essayé de recruter une une
équipe municipale c'est un monsieur qui
est venu me voir en décembre 2017 en me
disant on a pensé à vous pour vous soyez
le futur maire de Saint-Pierre descor
très bonne idée je lui ai dit mais c'est
quand les municipal donc vous voyez mon
niveau de politique presque négatif j'ai
fait venir mon épouse qui travaille à
côté de moi nous étions assis de part et
d'autre du cabinet médical du bureau du
d'examen et j'ai dit à mon épouse qui
rentre je lui dis voilà je te présente
Monsieur Alain Garcia il voudrait que je
sois le futur maire de Saint-Pierre
descor mon épouse a levé les yeux au cel
en disant bah voyons on a que ça à faire
donc voilà comment on a pu rentrer voilà
un peu comment je vois la politique en
fait on essaie de de rendre ce qu'on ce
qu'on ce qu'on a reçu parce que même si
on a beaucoup donné dans ce quartier
prioritaire on était installé au sein de
ce quartier prioritaire
on a quand même beaucoup reçu de cette
population et donc nous sommes allés en
fondant une équipe en recrutant une
équipe je m'en excuse monsieur le Carly
mais je vous l'avais dit en recrutant
une équipe qui allait se battre contre
99 ans et 6 mois de communisme avec une
une une une femme qui s'appelle Marie
France befil qui était maire ancienne
sénatrice qui finalement dans la fin du
mandat n'a pas eu l'occasion
probablement de tenir les les services
et de faire les choses qui étaient
nécessaires et c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi
je pense que ce parti a perdu les
élections municipales
dernières nous avons eu de grandes
difficultés d'abord dans le recrutement
de l'équipe municipale où j'avais
recruté deux de deux personnes une qui
était
au qui travaillait à pôleemploi et une
autre qui travaillait dans les
hôpitaux ces deux personnes il y a eu
des altercation je vais pas vous parler
tout ça parce que ça a été terrible j'ai
pris un directeur de cabinet que je
connaissais depuis très longtemps qui
est un musulman pratiquant avec de la
barbe avec qui je m'entends parfaitement
et il y a eu des altercations entre les
deux per ces deux personnes en fait qui
étaient dans l'équipe vous avez dans les
quartiers prioritaires et cela c'est
très étonnant vous avez des fois des
rivalités de réussite ça c'est quelque
chose que vous ne connaissez pas
probablement c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
jalousies extrêmement importantes
lorsque quelqu'un s'extirpe du quartier
prioritaire quand il est issu de
l'immigration c'est quelque chose de de
de de de surprenant mais ça existe donc
dans notre équipe nous avons eu euh deux
adjoints qui ét qui ont été touchés euh
gania bugadba qui était l'une des
premières familles d'immigration de
Saint-Pierre descor a eu deux fois sa
voiture brûlée donc deux véhicules
différents euh une adjointe qui a eu sa
maison la porte sa porte d'entrée de
maison
en Noël Noël
brûlé 2021 pardon on a tenté à deux
reprises de mettre le feu à mon cabinet
médical et la trème la 3oisème tentative
a été la bonne puisque dans la nuit du
1er au 2 septembre 2022 le cabinet
médical est parti en
fumée nous avons effectivement subi les
les les les les émeutes de plein fouet
et vous avez peut-être vu cette cette
vidéo qui a circulé qui a fait 10
millions de vues où je suis dans la
ville à un moment ma voiture est stoppée
par des poubelles et les jeunes mettent
le feu devant mes yeux et bah à la
voiture donc en leur disant je vous
trompez de cible j'ai été aussi exfiltré
monsieur de Carly comme vous
effectivement à ce moment-là mais j'ai
eu la chance de constater que parmi tous
ces émetiers qui étaient parfois très
jeunes il y en avait SEP qui voulaient
me faire la peau mais il y en avait 43
qui étaient autour et qui étit là en
disant si vous touchez au mer ça va mal
se passer c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
failli arriver un jeune a voulu s'en
prendre un mois il m'a donné un coup de
pied dans le dans dans le dans les
jambes ça m'a pas déstabilisé pour
autant le coup de pied n'était pas si
violent mais par contre ils lui sont
tombés dessus et ça a été terminé
voilà j'ai j'ai j'ai envie de vous dire
que il y a il y a des choses qu'il faut
qu'on fasse on a parlé du trafic de
drogue on vient de voter une loi sur
l'immigration mais on n pas pris en
compte les accords les accords
franco-algérien de
1968 et c'est bien
dommage et bien si c'est pas possible
dans une loi au moins on discuter dans
le débat madame si vous me permettez
mais je crois que c'est un c'est quelque
chose qui va falloir auquel on s'attache
de très très près parce que on ne peut
pas avoir une une une une façon
d'intégrer les personnes étrangères à la
France d'une autre manière et de manière
particulière pour un pays en particulier
je p P que c'est une question d'équité
n'y voyez je pense que vous partagez
pour la plupart ce qui se dit et puis
lutter contre ce trafic de
drogue lutter contre ce trafic de drogue
lut lutter contre la cocaïne qui en va
tous les milieux même les milieux les
plus riches lutter contre ça c'est c'est
c'est pervers ça tue notre société c'est
je vous assure qu'on va vers des des
temps qui ne sont pas bons voilà je vais
m'arrêter là parce que je pense que j'ai
j'ai pris juste un quart d'heure comme
vous me l'avez demandé parfait mais je
réponds à vos questions et je suis tout
oui à ce qui va se ce qui va se
présenter à nous merci beaucoup à vous
tous merci Monsieur le Maire peut-être
deux réponses immédiates à vos deux
dernières
questions la commission des lois à
laquelle vous participez ce matin va
décider en début d'année de travailler
sur les accords internationaux de la
France les accords bilatéraux de
différents pays et notamment avec
l'Algérie donc une mission sera mise en
place dans cette maison et enfin notre
collègue Jérôme Durin qui est ici membre
de la commission des lois préside
actuellement une commission d'enquête
sur le les trafics de stupéfiants enfin
narcotrafic exactement et fait partie de
ceux qui s'intéressent comme beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs à ce sujet mais qui
on av parfaitement conscience des enjeux
qui sont qui sont en qui sont à traiter
aujourd'hui
essayer de garder confiance dans dans
dans dans les élus de la République les
maires comme les autres d'autres certes
tout n'est pas parfait mais nous
arrivons quand même à travailler
collectivement ensemble sur beaucoup de
sujets malgré tout il faut le dire je
vous redonne la parole juste un mot pour
je m'en excuse parce que je me suis pas
excusé tout à l'heure j'étais en retard
parce que j'étais à la présidence du
Sénat j'étais reçu par Monsieur Gill
Lagarde donc je préfère le dire ça m'a
retenu un peu plus longtemps je m'en
excuse l'excus est
recevable merci
alors tout le monde a témoigné il y a
beaucoup de d'interventions madame stage
brigot madame Di Folco peut-être
d'autres chers collègues pas trop
longtemps pour que le plus d'entre nous
puissent s'exprimer qu'on puisse avir
des réponses merci monsieur le Président
d'abord je voulais juste apposer mon
soutien à ces quatre mères qui sont là
devant nous et pour lequel nous devons
en permanence rappeler notre soutien
quel que soit les col politiques et
cetera ça c'est pas le sujet voilà ce
sont des gens très impliqués on le con
on le sait et on sait on sait que ce
qu'ils ont vécu pendant les émeutes a
été partiement monstrueux violent et et
c'est une première quand même parce que
on a déjà connu des choses un peu
compliquées mais il faut quand même
noter que ce qui s'est passé fin juin
début juillet ça a été assez
exceptionnel et assez violent et je
voulais leur apporter évidemment mon
soutien vous avez tous expliqué votre ce
que vous avez vécu stéphanie a pas tout
dit parce qu'elle a pas dit toute la
suite quand elle a été dans sa voiture
et et je pense que c'est parce qu'elle
est discrète mais je sais ce qu'elle a
vécu cette nuit-là et une femme qui se
retrouve face à des gens violents qui
veulent juste se faire comme elle l'a
dit le maire j'imagine ce qu'elle a vécu
voilà c'est juste pour fermer cette
parenthèse moi je voulais dire deux
choses parce que vous avez tous dit
qu'il y avait beaucoup de jeunes donc ça
c'est vraiment un vrai sujet beaucoup de
jeunes il n'y avait pas que des jeunes
parce que je pense qu'effectivement
derrière il y avait des gens qui
manipulaient plus âgés mais une question
quand même deux choses avez-vous vu les
uns et les autres des filles dans ses
émeutes ça une question quand même hein
parce que cette violence je pense que
elle est souvent eximé par les garçons
donc est-ce que vous aviez
éventuellement vu des filles dans ces
soirées là se mêler au groupe de garçons
oui ou non et est-ce que vous avez dans
vos villes aussi parce que ça pas été
vécu de la même manière sur le
territoire connu des scènes de pillage
parce que vous avez parlé des meutes
vous avez parlé les uns et les autres de
de d'équipement brûlés cassés et cetera
avez-vous connu des scènes de pillage
dans vos communes voilà c'est juste ce
que je voulais sair merci Madame madame
diolco
oui merci président merci à vous quatre
pour votre témoignage qui était fort
intéressant et même émouvant par moment
on a pu mesurer la violence dont vous
avez fait
l'objet je voulais vous poser une
question par rapport aux destructions
des bâtiments dont certains d'entre vous
nous avez parlé en juillet nous avons
été saisis d'un texte en
urgence un projet de loi en urgence par
le gouvernement qui visait à faciliter
la reconstruction des bâtiments publics
dégradés notamment par
l'adaptation des marchés public pour
faciliter la reconstruction alors je
voudis savoir si ce texte qui a été voté
en urgence apporter des fruits et si
vous avez pu bénéficier de de facilités
merci merci madame difolco monsieur
Jérôme
Durin oui une question monsieur le
Président à au maire que je remercie de
de leurs interventions sur le lien entre
ces événements violents et et et le
trafic de drogue
euh qui est
présenté soit comme un élément
dstructurant la société soit comme un
élément structurant des émeutes et donc
du coup je je j'aimerais avoir des des
des des des précisions notamment sur le
rôle que pouvaient avoir
certains responsables locaux des trafics
à entrer dans les émeutes on voit bien
quel intérêt ils ont pu avoir en sortir
pour que le business reparte mais quel
rôle ils ont ont pu jouer dans le dans
l'animation de de de ces émeutes c'est
ce que j'ai cru comprendre de certaines
interventions monsieur Durin madame
narassigin
oui merci merci à tous les quatre pour
pour vos témoignages j'aimerais parce
que vous avez parlé monsieur de car de
de du fait que vous n'aviez pas été mise
au courant de l'intervention du Raid
j'aimerais savoir plus généralement
comment ça s'est passé avec les
préfectures notamment la la coordination
euh avec la police ou la gendarmerie
selon les les endroits où vous étiez
est-ce que justement vous avez a des a
des peut-être des des choses améliorer
justement dans ce dans ce genre de
situation sur la coordination entre les
services de la
préfecture les maires pour que les
choses se passent au mieux que vous
soyez mis au courant en temps réel de de
ce qui se fait chez vous et
éventuellement si vous avez des polices
municipales de la manière dont les
choses se coordonnent ou pas Salame
monsieur Roiron
oui moi je voulais poser la question
très simple notre collègue de l'Est de
la France a évoqué la question des
assurances il y avait eu des
propositions d'avancé où en êtes-vous
vraiment il y en a que un qui l'a évoqué
est-ce que cette question est est aussi
forte chez vous je pense notamment à
Saint-Pierre descor qui a été victime à
plusieurs moments de de question
d'émeutes voilà Emmanuel notamment toi
ça a été évoqué par Mame le ma de
Pontoise tout à l'heure me semble-t-il
SFF de ma part euh y y a-t-il d'autres
questions
oui merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse également au
collègues du grand test vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure que selon vous il
y avait des vraies motivations
politiques à ce qui s'est passé est-ce
que vous pourriez expliciter votre
propos s'il vous plaît merci et moi
avant de vous donner la parole dans
l'ordre que vous
souhaiterez j'ai deux questions la
première sur les réseaux euh on a évoqué
la question tout à l'heure est-ce que
pour vous les réseaux le dispositif a
joué dès le début ou est-ce que c'est
arrivé un petit peu plus tard c'est un
peu en décalé en clair est-ce que les
premiers actes de délinquence chez vous
ont été constatés quelques jours après
dès les premières heures et au quel cas
est-ce que les réseaux ont joué un rôle
extrêmement important ça c'est une prère
question une question vis-à-vis des des
personnes que vous avez rencontré et que
vous connaissez dans vos villages ou
dans vos communes j'imagine bien est-ce
qu'elles étaient toutes de la commune ou
est-ce qu'ell pouvaient et
potentiellement venir de l'extérieur de
de votre territoire ça ça nous paraît
aussi un point intéressant à à connaître
en fonction de ce qu'on a déjà entendu
hein dans les auditions qui ont été les
nôtres et sur le des assurances on l'a
évoqué c'est un sujet absolument
essentiel enfin ce que vous allez nous
dire va compter parce que ce qu'on nous
a dit il y a quelques semaines euh et
quel quelque peu différent pour ne pas
dire complètement différent donc il y a
un moment il faut que les choses soient
honnêtes et enfin ma dernière question
elle porte sur les relations avec les
procureurs de la République c'est vous
monsieur De Carli qui l'évoquz tout à
l'heure les relation avec l'institution
judiciaire dans la circulation de
l'information concernant la suite des
procédures qui ont été engagées sur les
plainte que vous-même avez vous avez pu
déposer c'est un point essentiel puisque
c'est un point sur lequel on insiste
depuis long longtemps singulièrement bon
depuis très longtemps ici mais
l'audition du MRE Saint-Brévin Lespin à
l'époque avait démontré un certain
nombre de choses et nous avons un texte
qui éta voté au Sénat qui devrait être
voté en principe au début de l'année à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vise à rendre
obligatoire la communication de
l'information entre le procureur de la
République et les maires dans un délai
d'un mois à compter du dépôt de plainte
et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite donc
ce sont des sujets qui pour nous sont
très importants voilà je sais pas dans
quel
ordre siz prévu quelque chose ou pas
monsieur decly
oui monsieur le Président j'ai pris j'ai
pris note des différentes questions
j'essaie de de balayer tout cela donc
concernant le public et meutier fille ou
garçon que des garçons aucune fille
aucune pas une euh la question des
pillages je ne peux pas dire que il y a
eu pillage en ce qui concerne par
exemple la mairie et et plus
particulièrement mon bureau dans mon
bureau il y avait une magnifique vitrine
dans laquelle étit exposé des ÉAU les
éot de l'anoui qui sont connus à
l'international et qui ont de la valeur
dont des émot anciens bah ils n'ont même
pas été volés ils ont été brisé voilà
euh sur euh la question posée sur la la
la loi voter
euh pour l'urgence à à reconstruire euh
en ce qui me concerne mais je pense que
les collègues ont fait la même chose le
bon sens voulait que nous n'attendions
pas en particulier pour l'école en
particulier parulier ou ou d'autres
bâtiments donc on a on a lancé
immédiatement nous les les démarches
administratives pour pour la
reconstruction passant autre même quel
quelques obligations parfois mais bon je
ne sais pas si la loi a facilité mais en
tout cas nous on ne s'est pas occupé que
qu'il a un vote de loi ou pas on a on
s'est lancé immédiatement dans la
reconstruction euh lien
émetier drogue moi j'en vois pas
absolument pas connait ce qu'on appelle
les caïdes quelques caïdes locaux de la
drogue ils étaient plutôt là avec leur
propres véhicule à essayer de calmer le
jeu pour que ça s'arrête mais il n'était
pas dans les ametiers
euh coordination entre les forces de
sécurité police gendarmerie et et et
nous-même moi je n'ai qu'à me louer du
honnêtement du travail mené par la
police on a un commissariat un hôtel de
police sur la ville dit qu'il manquait
de force donc il manque de moyens mais
euh c'est le 3ème commissaire qui dirige
ici et et on a de bonnes relations on
communique par SMS par téléphone
portable on s'appelle et cetera euh nous
menons régulièrement euh une fois par
mois des réunions sécurité en mairie à
laquelle je participe OIN de mes
adjoints et et le commissaire où son son
représentant est là également et on fait
le point des des situations euh la
gendarmerie je vous l'ai dit c'est
occupé de la ma sécurité celle de ma
famille et vraiment sont des gens
immense bienveillance très carrés
cartésiens et j'ai beaucoup apprécié
leur intervention en ce qui concerne la
préfecture je dois dire que nous avons
une nouvelle dit Madame le préfet
nouvelle préfette depuis le 22 août
dernier posé en préfecture de Nancy et
que depuis le 22 août elle est venue h
fois sur ma commune j'ai jamais connu ça
dans dans l'histoire préfectorale donc
depuis l'arrivée de Madame Souliman nous
avons effectivement un travail très très
proche elle sera présente sur ma commune
dans la nuit du 31 décembre au 1er
janvier et et donc je serai à ses côtés
également donc je tenais à vous le faire
savoir la question assuranciel elle est
je vous l'ai dit elle est elle est
énorme elle elle elle est angoissante
vraiment et moi je je vois pas pour
l'instant en tout cas le ciel s'éclairc
sauf à avoir obtenu une dérogation de 6
mois qui nous donne un peu de temps pour
pour travailler
mais la peur c'est effectivement les
propositions qui qui nous sonont faites
si nous avons des
propositions sur les
motivations politiques donc une une une
sénatrice me demande que je
précise je vais
préciser le maire de Saint-Pierre descor
c'est connais mon moi je suis membre du
Parti communiste français depuis l'â de
17 ans j'en ai 63 j'ai raconté
l'histoire de ma famille mon grand mon
AR grand-père était communiste italien
Il a fit le faschisme italien il s'est
réfugié en France en République il a
bien fait euh ce qui se passe en France
m'alerte un peu comme ce qui se passe en
Italie comme ce qui se passe en Hongrie
comme ce qui se passe dans de très
nombreux pays européens et donc oui ça
ça me ça m'inquiète et donc moi je suis
très fier de mon histoire et et je suis
un humaniste c'est-à-dire que j'essaie
de d'accompagner j'ai entendu ce que
fait ce qu'a fait ce que fait euh le
maire de Saint-Pierre descor en tant que
que professionnel de santé que son
épouse et je les félicite moi en tant
qu'enseignant ma femme est enseignante
on a on est au Secours populaire on a
toute notre vie et mes parents m'ont
appris cela c'est c'est donner du sens à
sa vie et de de tendre la main celles et
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin et de
n'oublier personne parce que quand on
oublie certains de toute manière d'abord
c'est pas bien et puis ça se retourne de
toute manière contre contre la
République et donc y compris quand on
veut mettre des gens en marge et je
ferai pas de commentaire sur ce qui
s'est passé hier mais voilà donc sur la
motivation politique pour moi c'est très
clair euh la seule mairie attaquée de
cette manière saccagée deout de font en
comble dans l'agglomération c'est la
mairie de montsain-martin et je peux
vous dire que la population que j'ai vu
dès le dimanche 1er juillet sur le le
marché dominical où ma femme m'a obligé
à à me rendre et bien la population est
solidaire de son maire ce qui a été dit
également par le collègue de
Saint-Pierre descor je je le reprends à
mon compte c'est-à-dire que euh certains
jeunes ont participé aux émeutes mais
l'immense majorité défend le maire et
les élus locaux et ça c'est c'est assez
rassurant donc on sur la motivation
politique moi elle est
clair et ça sert certains Paris parti
extrême et plutôt à l'extrême droite
visant une mairie de gauche et et j'en
veux pour preuve que en discutant avec
des jeunes issus de l'immigration
immigration algérienne marocaine ici on
a 40 nationalités d'origine différentes
qui vivent en paix et bien vous assistez
à des retournement de de cerveau
dirais-je de conscience des gens qui
vous disent ah ben on sait ce qu'on
votera la prochaine fois on votera
marine alors moi je leur dis mais ça va
pas et on me répond mais je suis
français je dis mais c'est pas que tu es
français mais tu es idiot voilà le type
de discussion franche que j'ai avec des
jeunes que j'ai eu à l'école même et
donc il y a pas besoin de faire de
campagne électorale c'est très clair
donc pour moi et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une différenciation j'ai expliqué que
certains jeunes du quartier ont brûlé
l'école ont brûlé le cessade et cetera
mais sur la mairie c'était un objectif
relayé par les réseaux sociaux puisque
j'étais dans une réception quelques
heures auparavant euh municipal et euh
certains m'ont alerté dans cette
réception montrant d'ailleurs des postes
sur fond noir c'était très lugubre que
il fallait brûler et attaquer tout ce
qui représentait la République en
particulier les mairies donc pour moi il
y a un lien évident
euh commune hmetier venant de la commune
extérieure donc j'ai répondu sur la
plupart des événements ce sont des
jeunes très peu nombreux de la ville
très jeunes sur la mairie ce sont des
gens de l'extérieur et ils étaient une
cinquantaine face à 15 fonctionnaires de
police qui n'ont pas pu tenir évidemment
et relation procure la République très
compliqué enin quand je dis très
compliqué euh distante ce que voulez
dire il en a pas j'en ai pas et et j'ai
pas d'information j'ai pas d'information
d'accord j'ai euh une question que j'ai
oublié personne n'a répondu à la
question mais en même temps vous l' pas
posé est-ce que la motivation des gens
qui ont commis ces actes étai en lien
pour vous avec l'affaire de départ qui
est euh la situation de nanter et le le
décès du jeune Naël non alors Monsieur
Monsieur François et puis après je
reviendrai monsieur decly ah oui
monsieur decly justement je je voulais
revenir parce que on on parlait et je
voulais revenir de l'influence des
partis politiques sur ce que sur ce que
vous avez dit euh alors peut-être
effectivement moi j'ai pas d'analyse
particulière je sais que dans les
milieux ruraux on a dit que la gauche
avait des influences je sais que dans
les milieux urbain l'extrême droite
avait des des influences je partage en
fait votre constat je me demande pour le
prochain mandat en tant que maire de
Saint-Pierre descor si je pourrais
exercer ma fonction avec le
rassemblement national au pouvoir c'est
la vraie question c'est ma vraie
interrogation je ne fais pas de jugement
sur le rassemblement national vous voyez
mais je me demande des difficultés qu'on
pourra avoir voir dans ces dans ces
milieux où il y a des quartiers
prioritaires mais comment allons-nous
faire mais j'en ai la cher de poule
quand je vous en parle je me dis ça va
être compliqué pour revenir sur le
pillage et pour répondre à votre
question sur les pillages effectivement
on a eu des pillages on a eu des
pillages de choses qui sont
intéressantes la pharmacie pour des
médicaments parfois interdit et puis les
bureaux de tabac puisque on a été
impacté sur la pharmacie les bureaux de
tabac en ce qui en ce qui concerne les
facilités de reconstruction et je pense
que c'est cette cette cette question est
intimement lié avec celle des assurances
que vous avez pu
émettre sur la facilité de
reconstruction on a quand même déjà
d'ors et déjà une assurance de la de la
préfecture d'engager des
fonds sur le reste à charge et sur les
assurances nous avons fait appel à des
experts d'assurés de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent au mieux défendre nos intérêts
par rapport aux experts d'assurance donc
je pense qu'on s on s'en tira pas trop
mal le lien entre les émeutes et le
trafic de drogue je vous ai parlé de
1968 lorsqu'il y a eu les éutes de 1968
on constate que depuis et là c'est le
médecin qui vous parle on constate très
singulièrement que les accès de violence
sont de plus en plus violent et
spontané avec une concentration de
produits actifs dans les choses consommé
qui est de plus en plus
importante il mériterait qu'on se penche
sur cette question et qu'on puisse
dépêcher une commission scientifique de
façon à ce qu'elle puisse nous en
avertir je crois que c'est très
important et il en va de l'équilibre de
cette nation puisqu'on a dit que la
drogue c'était quand même un vrai
fléo est-ce que les responsables locaux
sont entrés dans les émeutes les
responsables de trafic sont rentrés dans
les émeutes j'ai envie de vous dire non
est-ce qu'ils ont fait que on a pu s'en
sortir plus rapidement je vous dis pas
plus en 2005 en 2007 oui vous avez eu
des émeutes importantes ou qui ont duré
de de 3 semaines il me semble pour
certaines où là effectivement les
trafiquants se sont dit stop la
récréation est terminé il faut que le
business reprenne mais là ça n'a pas été
du tout le cas il y a eu une sol quand
même entre les familles des enfants qui
ont pris conscience que leur goss partai
à la dérive il y a eu aussi les servic
de l'enfance les services de la
politique de la ville je crois que
beaucoup on a uvré pour que ça s'arrête
d'un seul coup monsieur le Président et
c'est important en tous les cas c'est
mon témoignage sur Saint-Pierre descor
et sur la métropole de Saint-Pierre
descor où je suis viceprésident la
politique de la ville sur la métropole
de tour
pardon ensuite en ce que en ce qui
concerne la les relations entre la
préfecture le parquet et la police
nationale en fait il y a quelque chose
qui me gêne vous avez dit que vous avez
voté une loi sur la communication
obligatoire et c'est une excellente
chose par contre à aucun moment nous
avons pu être interpellés
interrogés reçu dans dans dans les dans
dans les commissions d'enquête sur les
vidéos qui circulaient mais croyez-vous
bien que moi en tant que médecin les je
jeunes qui ont fait des émeutes je les
connais je connais leur silhouettes je
connais leur façon dont ils se bougent
je les ai vacciné je les ai vu torsu
donc je sais de qui il s'agit mais à
aucun moment nous avons été interrogés
par la police et par le parquet qui mène
une enquête on a l'impression que la
justice et c'est son rôle on dit qu'elle
doit être absolument indépendante mais à
un moment donné quand vous avez des
acteurs du territoire qui connaissent
parfaitement leur population et qu'on
vient pas leur demander leur avis je me
pose des questions parfois sur la
pertinence des enquêtes excusez-moi de
me poser cette question en ce qui
concerne ensuite la communication on a
une préfecture quand même ou les préfets
et Monsieur de Carly l'a dit et je pense
qu'on a vécu tous les deux une situation
tout à fait similaire he il me semble he
Serge et je je pense franchement que la
préfecture a fait son travail on en
parle souvent et le préfet du fait des
émeutes ce qui n'était pas forcé le cas
dans les précédents contrats de ville
c'est interroger de la responsabilité
qu'il avait à faire le diagnostic et à
faire la construction du futur contrat
de ville ce qui est une chose
extrêmement importante donc il y a des
choses positives l'assurance j'en ai
parlé sur l'influence des partis
politiques on en a parlé une chose
intéressante comme question c'est celle
que vous nous avez posé sur le rôle des
réseaux l'action des réseaux alors dans
le
déclenchement ça a été probablement une
action qui a fait que le déclenchement a
été soudain spontané et a réuni un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont été
capables grâce au réseau de s'organiser
et de se rencontrer de de de d'être
d'être coalié dans les réseaux sociaux
on parle des réseaux
sociaux par contre des réseaux de trafic
ou mais on s'est exprimé sur la drogue
tout à l'heure je je je l'ai dit mais
moi je parle des réseaux sociaux par
contre les réseaux sociaux ils ont eu un
rôle dans la
compétition c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on a
incendié la voiture du maire à
Saint-Pierre descor et bien ceux de la
riche une commune voisine qui est aussi
dans le contrat de ville ils sont dit et
ben le maire de la riche il faut qu'on
lui fasse cramer sa bagnole et ils lui
ont fait cramer sa
bagnole donc il y a ce rôle là
et euh voilà en gros tout ce que j'avais
à vous dire de façon très très précise
et chos que j' par
merci Madame Stéphanie bon oui monsieur
le Président alors dans dans dans le
désordre sur je vais rebondir sur les
sur les réseaux mais alors à la fois
réseaux territoriaux euh et réseaux
sociaux qui sont qui me semble-t-il de
doivent être doivent être précisés sur
donc le déclenchement de de des émeutes
moi je pense et je l'ai dit depuis le de
début et j'en suis absolument convaincu
à la base il n'y a pas de de de cause
idéologique de de de déf enfin de
défendre des causes qui seraient contre
le système ou autrees je pense qu'il y a
le coup de colère qui qui a démarré à à
Nanterre mais c'est ensuite euh sur la
base des réseaux cette fois-ci
territoriaux et j'insiste là-dessus moi
je suis absolument convaincu et il y a
peut-être des différences d'analyse ou
des différences tout courts de situation
entre les différents territoires euh moi
je sais que chez moi clairement ce sont
sur les points d'î sur les quartiers qui
sont gangrainés par le trafic de drogue
euh qui sont où on veut nous montrer que
l'État a reculé que les forces
républicaines ont reculé et qu'ell
étaient sous le contrôle d'autres forces
c'était ça le signal c'était ça le
message et non seulement il a été reçu
mais il a été vécu je sais pas si
certains d'entre vous ont pu entendre
les forces de l'ordre durant ces trois
nuits les forces de l'ordre ont dit pour
la première fois de notre vie nous avons
reculé nous avons reculé nous avons cédé
le territoire moi quand j'ai eu le le le
la commissaire de de ma circonscription
je lui dis mais Madame la Commissaire
c'est une technique d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre de reculer pour mieux
revenir dit mais on n'est pas revenu on
a reculé euh et ça je peux vous dire que
c'est un élément qui me semble
extrêmement important parce que ce que
je vis encore aujourd'hui et
probablement mes collègues aussi vous
retournez dans ces quartiers la
confiance ils l'ont
la confiance est long je peux vous dire
que cet été sur un autre sujet qui
gangrainene nos quartiers qui sont les
rodéo jamais ils n'ont été à ce point
provoquant en contact aller provoquer
les différentes forces de l'ordre
qu'elles soi municipales ou ou
régalienne et ça j'en tire une
conclusion peut-être attive mais c'est
la conclusion que je tire c'est en lien
direct avec les émeutes où il y a eu un
bras de fer qui ont eu le sentiment
sinon de gagner en tout cas d'enfoncer
des lignes clairement et je pense que
les forces de l'ordre ne vous diraient
pas ne vous diraient pas autre chose et
c'est pour ça que je fais le lien avec
les trafics de drogues et ces fameux
territoires perdus de la République
parce que c'est précisément pour montrer
que l'État sous toute sa dans dans dans
sa globalité hein que ce soit l'état
régalien ou ou ou ou les les
collectivités locales n'ont plus leur
mot à dire sur ces sur ces sur ces
territoires parce qu'ils sont contrôlés
par d'autres forces et ces forces vous
l'aurez compris c'est ce que je
considère comme étant la gangraine
aujourd'hui de notre pays ce sont les
trafics et les réseaux et les réseaux de
de de
drogue donc pas de côe idéologique une
véritable volonté en revanche de
contrôler les territoires et je je ça en
vient avec la question Jacqueline age
brino sur les pillages oui il y a eu des
pillages mais des pillages ciblés des
pillages sur la base de de j'allais dire
de denré ou de biens qui pouvaient être
ensuite recommercialisés donc on est
vraiment dans la logique de business
voilà donc il y a pas de cause politique
il y a pas de C on est dans du business
contrôle de territoire et du business en
tout cas c'est c'est vraiment moi comme
ça que je l'ai que je l'ai vécu les
filles on les a pas vu si on avait elle
devait être enfin on en a vu
quelquesunes mais c'est elle remp
plusiss les coffres voilà en tout cas
elles étaient pas elles étaient pas au
contact moi je voudrais saluer la
coordination avec la coordination avec
les services de l'État et et plus
particulièrement de la
préfecture je tiens ici vraiment à
saluer le préfet du valdoise PhIP
Philippe court pour pas nommé que
j'avais moi mais comme je pense la
plupart de mes collègues touché une à
deux fois par jour au
téléphone et avec lequel de manière très
libre de manière très réactive et de
manière très directe nous élaborions
même les stratégies enfin stratégist à
bien grand mot mais en tout cas les
positionnements coordonnés de nos forces
réciproques euh c'est ainsi que nous
avons décidé sur les deux quartiers qui
flambaient euh dans j'allais dire d'en
abandonner un en tout cas cas de comme
un brziier de cesser de l'alimenter et
l'alimentation qui était les bûches
pardon le dire comme ça c'était les
forces de l'ordre parce qu'il y avait
des tractnats quand même he les forces
de l'ordre étaient attiré parce qu'il
voulaient casser du flic et donc
ensemble nous avons décidé sur un des
deux quartiers ni plus ni moins que de
retirer les forces de l'ordre en se
disant il y aura plus de matière il y
aura plus de matière inflamable il y
aura plus de raison de de de de
s'échauffie si si je puis dire ce choix
ayant été fait parce que ce quartier
était relativement éloigné des autres et
en pariant sur le fait que du coup le
brziier s'éteindrait de lui-même c'est
ce qui s'est produit et ça a permis donc
de relocaliser la totalité des forces de
l'ordre encore une fois d'État
c'està-dire la police nationale puisque
Pontoise est en zone police mais nous
avons eu le le soutien de la gendarmerie
qui a été évidemment rapatrié depuis le
le le Vexin et puis les les briades de
beaumontsuroise ont été ont été
positionné sur sur Pontoise et puis bien
entendu la la la la police municipale
avec des situations cocasses mais là
aussi j'essaie toujours de retenir les
éléments positifs de pouvoir constater
sur le terrain les différentes
techniques d'intervention entre police
nationale et et et gendarmerie nationale
c'est c'est un petit clin d'œil qui a
nécessité quelques quelques ajustements
mais qui au final ont montré là encore
une véritable efficacité une
coordination et je tenais vraiment à à à
redire la réactivité l'écoute et
l'efficacité du préfet du valdoise dans
ces dans ces moments extrêmement
extrêmement
compliqués le pendant c'est
malheureusement la effectivement
relation très distante pour le moins
avec le procureur de la République que
je qualifierais j'ai dit distante en
réalité
d'inexistante voilà ni plus ni moins ce
que je trouve dommageable puisque dans
toutes ces périodes on sait très bien
que ce qui compte et ce qui fonctionne
et ce qui qui rend les choses efficaces
c'est le fameux continuum de sécurité
qui inclut tous les acteurs y compris
municipaux d'ailleurs mais qui vont
jusque au service du ministère de la
Justice et je pense que là encore il y a
il y a des des des réflexions ou des ou
une culture
d'approche des choses qui qui doit être
profondément revue travaillé ou une
sensibilisation mais en tout cas on on
on yy est pas on y est pas encore sur
les assurances on a parlé sur les
motivations politiques moi me
semble-t-il chez nous il y en avait pas
et je crois avoir répondu à vos
questions merci merci beaucoup à vous
quatre je crois que je constate qu'il y
a pas d'autres questions moi je voudrais
on va bien sûr lever notre dision mais
mais vous redire sincèrement au nom de
tous les collègues de la commission des
lois d'abord merci d'être venu et merci
d'avoir été aussi précis et
clair ce dont nous avons besoin dans le
travail qui est le nôtre c'est de la
clarté de la sincérité pour qu'on puisse
à tous les niveaux pour qu'on puisse
faire un diagnostic qui soit le plus
exact possible et potentiellement
proposer des solutions naturellement on
a bien compris que le sujet était
multifactoriel on a bien compris que le
sujet ne venait pas spécialement des
événements de nantair ça avait été un
élément mais on a bien compris la
compétition par voie de réseaux sociaux
ce que j'ai fait à tel endroit tiens moi
je vais faire mieux que ailleurs était
réel on a bien compris que le rapport à
l'autorité dans certains cas était réel
aussi c'est un vrai sujet Monsieur le
Maire de de Carly monsieur de Carly l'a
dit donc il y a un travail immédiat de
réponse immédiate d'ordre public
j'allais dire et puis il y a un travail
plus profond plus recherché sur comment
dans les années qui viennent pour ne pas
dire dans les mois qui viennent on
reprend en main le respect tout
simplement d'une certaine manière et la
capacité à pouvoir se projeter dans
l'avenir pour un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui n'y voi pas grand-chose
pour l'instant ENF c'est à peu près ça
bien on va pas tirer de grandes leçons
mais en tous les cas un grand merci à
vous je suspends je souhaite une
excellente journée oui et de bonne fête
de Noël également oui monsieur de
François j'en profite parce que Monsieur
de Carly est là moi je m'interroge dans
une société où on prône la parité de
voir que nos enfants en maternel et en
élémentaire dans les premières années de
leur vie n rapport qu'à des personnels
féminins et jamais de personnels
masculins a si peu quelle société et ça
Serge j'aimerais bien que peut-être
qu'on arrive à s'en à s'appeler
là-dessus parce que je m'appuierai sur
votre grande expérience de de de
professeur et c'est une question que je
soulève régulièrement en disant quelle
société veut-on construire en ayant
comme rapport à l'autorité au tout début
de la vie soit un homme soit une femme
c'est une question que je pose mais
c'est une question de fond on va pas
routre ce matin mais la question de la
féminisation de beaucoup coup de
métiers avec tout le respect qu'on a
pour nos les femmes de ce pays il y a un
sujet à un moment c'est clair d'accord
Serge on essaie de s pas facile à
traiter hein ou il y a pas de souci
pascicou bon ben vous vous vous appelez
entre vous hein et puis vous nous direz
le résultat Merci à VOUS excellente
journée je vous redis bon Noël à tous
vous aussi
merci